le but pour nous
bien que
ce qui nous inquiète avec cette
proposition noir alors il ya plusieurs
choses d'abord on tient à redire qu
évidemment nous sommes contre
l'avortement puisque l'avortement
quels qu'ils soient qui soit deux jours
ou à neuf mois élimine un être humain
une petite vie humaine cette proposition
doit cependant est inquiétante puisque
en fait c'est une c'est toujours un
parent en plus vers une idéologie de
plus en plus mortifères c'est aussi un
acte qui est à la fois dangereux pour la
femme est dangereux pour les médecins
pourquoi parce qu'à tout ça d'entre
douze et quatorze semaines ya quand même
une grosse différence dans la pratique
de l'avortement parce qu'on est face à
un bébé dans le crâne est aussi fier un
bébé dans les membres sont parfaitement
informés
[Musique]
il est important pour nous de reprendre
la parole avec effectivement tout ce
peuple européen qui défend les valeurs
de la vie et reprendre la parole et
convaincre l'assemblée
le parlement européen de l'importance du
sérieux de la force politique de la
force sociale de la force également je
dirais axiologique des valeurs que
représente la la défense de la vie en
europe
[Applaudissements]
prenez soin des français prenez soin des
français prenez soin de la vie la vie ce
n'est pas du jetable la vie c'est de la
tension les uns pour les autres et on
est tous reliés les uns aux autres et
prenez soin des familles qui sont les
foyers où il ya de la vie et où il ya de
l'amour parce que c'est ça qui constitue
la base de la solidarité de la société
française
micro macro